Wow.
Well go to your mom's house.
Christina Dee Dee,
true
Dj Guide,
math exclusive.
Nice sounds made the beat.
This is sorta like when,
uh,
Tony Charge said that,
you know,
gangster and made a song for him.
You know,
I'm like
top of the mountain.
What are you saying?
This is all nonsense.
Whatever your saw the Djs in down to me
just doesn't concern.
No,
I,
it doesn't at all.
Did you brush your teeth?
You didn't.
Your teeth looked like devos right now.
Preston,
it's Brown and you smiled earlier and it's just ground flecks of stuff in there.
You say rude things cause you brushed today.
Any more rude stuff you've got to say or no,
I am mine at a whole list.
You a plug your farts real quick.
I'd love to Tom Guys,
come see me live.
September 27th,
8:00 PM,
uh,
Seattle,
Washington.
I said to come on comedy clubs,
so it's technically to come on.
Yeah.
December 28th in Shortland,
Oregon,
a helium comedy club.
October 4th,
Dallas.
Tay Hos that's high in his comedy club.
October 5th,
Houston,
Texas at the secret group.
October 23rd uh,
mommy,
Apolis,
Ghana at mortise comics,
and then October 24th at the very famous Cincinnati,
Ohio would go bananas.
So doing the one our shows,
get your tickets@thousandranchdotcomspelledoutthousandanch.com.
Ignore him.
Okay.
He's fine.
Look right.
Oh,
there he goes.
Let's hit pause for a minute.
Yeah.
Okay,
sure.
Let's see how this goes back.
I came back,
I just belched together.
Put that baby down of things.
Why was I,
you were talking about,
uh,
okay.
Go Bananas.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to Cincinnati obviously,
you know,
October 24th to do one standup show at go bananas.
But I'm also going to be making a pilgrimage to the hotel.
I'm going to request to stay in room six one eight now eight oh eight nine eight
oh wait,
I'll go up.
I'll go up to eight oh eight and I'll kiss the,
the number my hands to pay all mush
anyways.
tickets@thousandranch.com that's t h o u s a n d ranch dotcom.
Please come see me.
It'll be fun.
We can all be in a triple d round tits.
Oh,
what's the head?
Liberty Township
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
Who's with me?
Pat House was a lot of vocal fry.
Of course.
Pat House.
Come with me next week.
The July,
1415 16 I met the American comedy company in San Diego Hole.
That's good.
Sandy Ales.
Good.
Who?
A whole California.
And then Saint Lou's tits the week after Missouri.
Um,
a bunch of other dates going to be more be a whore.
I dunno,
they're all at Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com.
So if you want tickets to go to town square.com,
click on the show's page.
All of them are there.
Where else is there?
Oh,
I got some suggestions.
Come on.
A bus,
Ohio for Houston.
Huge Com.
Okay.
And Indianapolis a million floppy tits.
It's good.
I like it.
Cause solid works.
Yep.
As of course I've told you guys,
Charlotte is a in October,
uh,
Jude or kitties in September and fill her up Delphia in November.
Um,
so that's it.
You think jeans.
I know.
It's pretty great.
Yeah.
It was a good,
good cities.
Um,
James,
you want to take over?
Yeah.
Sorry,
I got to pull.
Um,
oh.
I just love this product.
I now,
my entire underwear drawer is overtaken.
You're going to do that in the middle of my reading was it doesn't affect it.
I mean it's that kind of does.
It didn't,
I didn't hear anything.
What'd you pushed and did you shit in your pants?
Oh No,
I'm fine.
Do you think the sponsor wants you to Fart in the middle?
Maybe started from the top and say,
this episode is brought to you by.
All you said was,
I love this product.
Okay,
you're ready to start the show jeans.
Oh yeah,
let's do this.
That's what can
happen.
It's always something
with a bag of feces in hand.
He doesn't a tape running up behind an unsuspecting woman and shoving the waist
down her shorts.
Watch from another angle.
She's on the phone and never sees it coming.
Man gets away.
How disgusting is that?
That's fight city seems to be going down.
Yeah.
No,
bring in one.
Loving to them.
No bond.
Oh No.
Go,
go to your mom's house.
Christina,
where'd you find that?
Anyways,
that's even mismatch.
The top that does I even go with that.
Yeah.
Forced it on there,
man.
You're such bullshit.
I brought her with me to a basketball today.
Play basketball.
I shot hoops.
You and Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
I love your 30 year old references.
Every bad.
Imagine my basketball today.
Three times and all three times.
She's like,
okay.
Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
As can we get somebody who's not near death with Kareem.
He's what?
I know.
You're really dating yourself in the Harlem Globe trotters.
They were all good.
Are you 70 curly?
There's,
you know a little,
yeah,
yeah.
I tell Ya,
a Corinne was something to the Sky Hook.
He had his little short shorts back then.
The Lakers all had their,
the ball in the 80s did.
Can you talk about modern day?
Because my dad was watching it in the night and see it cause he watched it.
Listen,
I don't watch that shit.
You know,
we gotta get,
we gotta telling you we've got to put basketballs in his crib.
The new every agency,
free agency day one of free agency was a what?
Yesterday or the day before.
That's basketball contracts.
Oh,
day one.
The NBA teams collectively spent 1.7 billion signing damn players.
1.7 bill.
Did the Lakers get good people?
No.
It's Corinne playing cream creams back.
Yeah.
They sign them up to see like nine,
four years.
175 million.
Oh Wow.
No,
they were really outrageous.
Condrey guys you've never heard of.
We're getting like 18 19 million a year.
Wow.
Yeah.
And they have really,
really outrageous.
Doesn't play anymore.
He's done.
He retired.
Just retired.
Oh,
that was his last season.
The one that just ended,
but he's like 35.
Right.
How old is Corinne?
Kobe?
I don't know.
I think a year I blew Ben.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
well get your summer die haircut looking good.
Both of you got summer dog cuts.
37 to now.
Yeah.
See he'll be 38 next month.
Okay.
Is he still with that gold digger check?
Um,
the girl who he,
he brought her back with the ring as well as the story.
Don't like her.
Really?
Yeah.
That's the story.
I wonder what his dad got really upset when he found out she was,
he was marrying a Hispanic girl.
Oh,
that was a race thing.
Racing.
Yeah.
Oh,
please.
Yeah.
I know.
There are multicultural.
The Kobe's they,
he was raised in Italy,
Italy.
I know that.
That's all I know about him is he was like this European,
a phenom.
Right.
They should be more open minded
now.
I know.
Sure.
There's more to it than that.
Well,
that was,
you know,
he had a really tumultuous relationship with his family the last Kobe.
Yeah.
Hmm.
They weren't close.
Interesting.
What did he say to you about it?
Well,
via text or over the phone,
cause it's different stuff.
I mean,
this is well known.
I'm not making this stuff up.
Oh,
I'm not,
I don't think you are.
Yeah.
No,
it's well known stuff.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
Kobe,
I love that.
Oh,
I remember this.
Sit here for you guys.
He was so broken up over this God pork.
I know.
A suffering man.
Furious at myself.
Yeah.
It's kind of a delay on the sound.
A little bit
disgusted at myself.
He's so handsome.
Good looking guy.
He stuck it in some girl in Colorado.
Yeah.
And,
and so,
and then what happened?
So the wife found out it was a big deal.
Well,
it wasn't just the way fat.
No,
I think the girl accused him of rape.
I remember now.
Sorry about that.
I forget the stories.
It was so long ago,
you know,
I think she gives him a rape because of how bad are the biggest most he was
after that,
you know.
Uh Huh.
Could you a picture,
is that the technical,
is that what the court said?
What kind of Dick this guy has got it.
Oh,
for sure.
Kobe's carrion.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
The Salami on this guy talking about assault rifles.
Salami.
Yeah.
Look at the wife.
She's just like,
she looked at me,
mother fucker.
I'm going to get a ring.
I'm going to get a fucking bracelet.
You know Lamborghini.
Oh yeah,
we got her to fucking always person.
Personal counting right now.
Yeah.
I'm so sorry.
Did they have kids together?
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
I don't know if they had them at this point.
It's not listened to.
Poor Kobe.
I don't think he's up.
Do you think he was he proven to the no.
Yeah.
I don't think that guy seems sweet.
I think it
comes with the territory.
If you play in the NBA.
I think so.
Yeah.
They're like,
get your deck ready and get it out because this is going to do a lot of stuff.
Right.
Well you're not just training to play basketball here.
You're going to do a lot of fucking guys the most ball too.
But yeah.
But I think more football or basketball basket.
Why do you think that is?
I think it's just like the short shorts,
you know?
First of all there's less.
You're not actually physically wrecked.
Usually after a basketball game going can be tired,
but you're not like,
I think my shoulder broke and like,
you know,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
And that's true,
that culture of like at a game,
like the environment is a little more,
I dunno.
I think,
yeah,
it's like a social thing.
Nicholson comes to the games,
celebrities sit on the whatever.
It's an exciting thing to go to the shooting hoops and he going to take a shower
and going go,
fuck yeah.
What about tennis ball?
Your Lens?
I'm gonna have surgery right now and there there was a carried off on stretchers
or where was that?
Tennis.
Those guys must throw it around the most.
Then they probably thought it out and I feel like they're always tennis.
Big tennis stars are usually in relationships.
I feel like basketball's away more.
You know the thing is basketball for a while that you could jump in the NBA from
high school.
So guys were coming in,
guys come in as teenagers and there's all this money and they're traveling every
night.
It's not like football.
There's 16 games,
basketball,
there's 82 is,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
So it's like,
you know,
it's a long season and it's a smaller group so they get usually tighter.
You know,
you have a smaller group of people who become friends and I think it's,
it's the environment is also more into like the nightclub and you know that
going out like that,
that's bigger in the NBA.
Gotcha,
Gotcha.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Just like Comedians,
same thing.
Yeah,
totally.
Man.
Comedian should be way more irresponsible than we are.
Like we kind of hold it together more than most people don't.
We compared to the NBA.
What comedians are you talking first of all,
what's that football player?
You and Aja,
we're talking about that guy that has like 40 kids.
There's a fee one who's notoriously oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Antonio Cromartie yeah,
we've played them on the show.
Right.
But I'm saying like Louis C K doesn't have 12 children.
We don't have a lot of money.
Now I know what come on.
I mean,
no,
but it's not just football.
That's sport.
I mean basketball players.
There's baseball guys too that have that a lot of basketball and football
players.
The guy that like first brought that whole um,
you know,
phenom that that idea on into the,
into the culture was a basketball player.
Sports illustrated did a piece on a player named Shawn Kemp back in the early
nineties cause he had seven kids in like seven different cities.
Like it was all on his basketball schedule whenever teams
and everyone was like seven kids.
It's crazy once you know,
it is pretty outrageous since then it's gone numbers for other people.
I've gone way up.
Yeah.
Isn't it?
Isn't it interesting now that we have a child and don't you feel like the 19
kids and counting woman is the most reckless or a piece of human shit?
The Duggar's,
the Duggar's think it's so irresponsible and it was even more reckless.
So blame it on religion to be like,
well,
if old JC didn't want me to have one of these,
you know,
he just stopped letting me have him.
God invented birth control too.
Right?
Well that's the,
that's that's considered sacrilege.
That's so offensive to everybody to just say,
we're going to drain the system.
Like the bird
of each of these.
He lives on this world and the excuse is just like,
God wouldn't let me have these if I wasn't supposed to.
Those nut bags are part of a movement called quiver fall.
And really basically what they're doing is populating enough of themselves to
eventually,
the goal is to get them into government positions and to be public leaders and
to crave more nuts basically.
You know,
it's what the Catholics do to,
we create a lot of nuts.
A wage to Kimono.
No,
no,
I like it.
It's very nice.
The nighttime shows.
So if I were a conservative leader,
I would support that idea because that,
I feel like,
at least here,
that the conservatives are definitely behind politically.
They have less stars,
less big names.
Yeah.
You know,
they are,
they are our nutbag.
So get proven well.
Some of them are not,
not bags.
My thing is that I think
there's a definite shift where you feel like more,
especially the youth is more progressive,
right?
More liberal.
So if you're a conservative,
you go like,
we have to find some way to combat this seemingly endless progression of
progressives.
You know,
and one of the ways you could do is be like,
look,
all you Super Christians,
you got to start fucking lot more having a lot of kids so that at one point
maybe there'll be more of us,
you know their whole thing.
Yeah,
I understand that.
I'm saying it's crazy,
but I understand the thought behind it.
Yeah.
Great.
So this video was actually sent by my friend Shawna,
who lives in a sentence.
Well she sent it to me,
I don't know,
blue band also picked it up,
but Shawnee sent this apparently,
and she goes,
look what's happening in my city right now.
Yeah.
This is pretty neat guy taking them.
He's taken shifts is putting it in bags and stuffing that bag into people
shorts.
What does what have been,
especially in the summer.
That's gotta be a really special,
you don't get that everyday.
No,
he's not.
He doesn't hesitate running up behind an unsuspecting woman and shoving the
waist down her shorts from another angle phone and never sees it coming.
The man gets away.
How disgusting is that?
Yeah.
That's a bold move.
Take your shit.
It's Kinda neat though,
right?
Well,
I wouldn't use
my shit of what a fee.
They could do some test and figure out who you are you to go for it.
No,
you want to do that.
I do someone else's shit or dog shit.
I mean your criminal mind is definitely working,
but I feel like the exciting part is to be like you took my shit.
Yeah.
I can tell.
I totally get this by the way.
I totally get it.
What a thrill.
What assigning groups.
I know it's pretty funny.
He was a prankster.
I think he's a severely mentally ill.
Drifter.
Probably has a couple of murders.
Unders.
No,
no,
no.
This is just college prank.
Eyebrow.
You on camera doing this where you took a shit and put it in a baked potato and
put it under some guise pillow.
You did all that.
I didn't the Shanti.
I should in a,
you know what I did?
I shouldn't have Ziploc bag.
I put it in a pillow.
What's the diff,
you said a baked potato?
Well that's called a shanty.
You've put it in a baked potato and then he puts in foil on it and then you hide
it and the guy's closet.
And then it stinks over time.
Now I learned this from a frat boy that I worked with at a company called world
link.
Okay.
10 years ago,
know what I did was I shit it was a hot,
like a hot five minutes.
Talk about it.
It was a,
I think it was coming out of summer into fall was still real hot and I shit into
a Ziploc bag.
Now how did you do that?
Let's be,
how did you,
it was one of those ziplocs that actually has the,
it's in a gallon size cause I imagine at one,
yeah,
it was a big one.
And then the regular seal,
but the,
you know,
Zoopla?
No,
no,
but the kind you can slide it over.
Yes.
So yeah,
I just,
I was like,
I gotta do it over a toilet.
I got a hot one in me and I stood a squad and I held it open and I was able to,
it was like a real mushy out one.
It kind of plopped in there.
I sealed it up.
Um,
Bill Bailey and red shared that were were roommates freshman year of college and
we used to play,
we played some games,
some card game kings,
is that what it was called?
Um,
every Thursday we would play that because that's also in south park would come
on and we,
we uh,
you know,
bills in on it.
I go,
I'll put it in reds pillow and then,
you know,
we'll,
we'll just watch him discover there's a bat shit is.
So anyways,
I put it in there and we find out that like reds out of town or red,
red's not coming back.
So we off fuck,
they ain't got the luggage bag.
I know.
So I'm like,
well I guess this,
this whole prank is over,
so I take this shit and I throw it out of the dorm,
like third floor or throw it right.
And it just lands out in the field somewhere.
And so that's Thursday.
So Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday,
Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
it's out there.
I figure it's gone.
Red Is back in town.
We'll go,
let's just see.
It's there.
It's cooking in the sun.
Take it again.
Put it back in his pillow.
Play cards of course were laughing so hard at stupid shit,
but it looks like we're laughing at each other's jokes because somebody says
something really mundane and everybody busted out laughing because we're just
thinking about him.
The bag of shit.
Yeah.
You guys don't see dorm rooms or small.
It is the sheer,
no,
we couldn't smell it from there.
So he,
but he gets up in the,
he's on the top bunk and then he's like,
I'm going to heat this Omaha.
We're like,
all right.
Then all of a sudden we're like,
we're counting like one,
two,
three,
and like almost on cue.
Then five seconds he goes,
I'll go change my fucking shoots.
So we're like,
he's like,
oh,
it's drinks.
It's starts taking the sheets off and we're just bracing ourselves.
Um,
he takes his pillowcase and he was like,
what the fuck?
And dumps it over and a bag of shit falls out.
Man.
He was so fucking heated.
He was so upset.
He,
he picked it up and he threw.
And I remember I came right by my face.
Did the ZIP lock bag open?
No,
but you know him and bill went to the Ziploc brand.
It actually should be a Ziploc ad.
I know.
And actually I was hoping that this way might reach some of their people.
You don't know now might this episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you buy
Ziploc shitting in a bag of shit and keep on shit.
So when he threw it,
bill threw it back and it basically was,
you know,
almost a brawl,
right?
Yes.
And somebody definitely ratted on me,
but I,
I was able to deny the charges.
Who ratted you out was the thing.
I don't know,
but I was like not fungus.
Of course somebody did.
Somebody did.
And it's the only,
they ratted me out probably.
It wasn't probably the inner circle is one of those things where it got out like
Tom Shit.
Guys bragged somebody I didn't get caught.
That's how they always get card.
Denied it for six,
seven years.
Wow.
His wedding.
I told them
what is special.
I told him,
did you whisper in his ear?
I toast.
I gave him a toast and I told them I'm the one that shit in your pillow case.
It was like his glass.
What a special gift.
But I love him.
I love him.
But say you're saying you understand the logic of the New York shitter and this
is a good idea.
This is very dear to me.
And I read the poop Heil.
Yes.
Do you want to explain to people?
I do.
I don't.
I want youtube because I don't believe you.
This is one of those stories that you've been trying to sell me on for like,
or that's bullshit.
You've been benign.
Yeah.
So such a lie.
I told you that my junior year,
um,
CJ,
Jay Reed and got an apartment off campus freshman and sophomore year.
We lived on campus junior year we had an apartment senior here.
We moved to another one junior year.
It was this really like out in the woods kind of apartment complex,
about 10,
15 minutes away from campus.
And in the summer we live there.
Justin didn't leave there,
but Casey and I did.
And we also had other roommates people,
I dunno,
whatever.
It was a weird neighborhood,
but every other day we would go in the backyard and we built this,
there was a a natural ladder,
but we built like a seat off a ladder and we would take shit from there onto the
ground and the whole idea was build a poop pile so everybody would,
the neighborhood kids were like,
I want to take your shit there.
And we'd let them and then every
buddy would just,
oh yeah,
I don't believe this.
I know you didn't try to sell me this story.
I think you're lying.
Number one.
Why would you like this neighborhood kid thing?
Yeah.
You just added that fact to it by the way.
No I didn't.
Yeah,
you did.
People from all over the apartment complex would shit their,
yeah,
you did.
So now this is a new fact that you've been adding.
No,
I didn't.
I've heard the story like a million times something.
I don't fucking listen to details now we will announce when we go.
This is the London.
Everybody wouldn't mind to try to show.
This is the lie.
That's not a lie.
Not First of all.
People don't line up to take shit when you got it yet.
It's on your time.
No,
you don't.
Everybody on his shit.
Everybody wanted to poop.
This is how I know it's a total life.
Okay,
I'm going to make you do a polygraph on this series.
How would I make this a man?
Can we look into getting a polygraph test?
Because I've heard the fucking poo pile story now I'm not.
I'll since we first started dating,
you tried to convince me.
Justin's tried to convince me.
He's not trying to convince you.
It's telling you this is you guys are in on the stupid stupid line.
I call them and see if I'm making it up.
Dude,
we've done this before and then he knows the story and then he,
he makes up some shit to the only reason we'd a polygraph.
That's the only way.
By the end of that summer,
remember Jurassic Park when they find the dinosaur mountains,
the shit was like that.
It was like a thousand shits in one time.
That is
so,
and where was it in relation to your windows and your rooms and stuff is in the
backyard.
You guys had it.
A pile of human feces in your backyard is what you're trying to sell me on a
huge,
huge amount.
Nobody would let that.
If you lived in an apartment complex that wouldn't,
you've never lived in North Carolina.
That's where I lived.
You're telling me that all the people that lived in the apartment complex,
we're like,
we like this poop pile.
Then it was,
they're lining up to shit from a ladder until Billy ladder.
They thought it was awesome.
This is total way to shit on it.
We want the listeners don't know is that you have been trying to sell me this
bullshit story for 11 years and you're the one that brings it up a functionally
retarded in the night believe everything.
If I can say,
oh,
I don't,
I know you're lying,
lying.
I'm not sure why we should on that thing for a hundred days in a row and sort of
everybody in that complex.
Okay.
There wasn't one person who was like,
I don't want to pile of everyone's shit in my backyard.
There wasn't another woman that was like,
guys,
I'm not so sure.
No,
because smelled the summer and as soon as lies what you disliked it.
They didn't tell us so they liked it.
Their kids like shit.
They're saying it as a lie.
No,
it's not.
It's been lying.
Nobody,
nobody ever said,
hey,
we got to stop this.
[inaudible] you just added that the whole neighborhood stood in line and the
children were cheering.
When we weld plan,
I like that.
Everybody would line up for shit.
The children and they come.
Yes.
Okay.
I'm telling you,
it's such a line.
Sometimes guys would come home from work and they take,
your state would come right there and shit there.
I'm serious.
Polygraph blue man.
Find out how much it'll cost and we're going to do it.
I'm sick of hearing this story for years.
I've been hearing this nonsense.
Anyways,
it's the 4th of July.
It's Americans Hall.
It's my favorite.
I love drinking in public with people.
I love going out with the general public and he's standing in parks and looked
at fireworks.
You don't like 4th of July?
I like,
I like America and I love our independence.
I don't like to go anywhere where there's groups of people drinking,
staring at the sky and I've never really been all over me.
I never liked,
I never liked the,
uh,
the huge crowds,
but I don't like huge crowds on any day.
Now what I dread is when Elis gets older and he's going to want to see stuff and
then we're going to have to do shit like go see fireworks.
Today is also every year the big,
uh,
Nathan's hot dog eating.
Yes.
Most importantly,
it used to be really into this more.
I feel like hot dog eating guns.
This was,
I loved it.
I still do.
But then,
you know,
life took over.
Responsibilities took over.
But I'm of your homeboy was a Kobayashi,
right?
It wasn't your guy.
I love to Curio Kobayashi.
He was my favorite for many,
many years.
He trained really hard.
He's the kind of guy that he would eat cabbage for weeks ahead to expand his
stomach.
He would do a lot of physical exercise to be fit outside,
super foot black widow Sonia at Thomas,
she weighed like 90 pounds.
Little Asian girl.
The Ifo.
See,
I'm a huge fan.
She was good at winks.
She was the wing champion,
right?
I do,
yeah.
I read a book about it.
I,
I'm fascinated.
It's,
it actually started as a,
as a goof obviously.
And then these two guys started the IFO,
see and it became,
it became what it is famous.
They have other events,
by the way,
not just hot dog eating.
It was the tip of our hat.
I mean,
it's already over.
But uh,
just before the event,
we have a,
this clip from one of the competitors,
Richard Franco check this.
Right,
right.
Go.
Not just a competitor,
but the favorite to win the hot dog eating contest.
It's the most you can eat in five minutes.
So Richard,
I,
how often do you practice for something like,
I know my,
you know,
my parents might fool you.
I'm,
I'm on.
Been on a giant diet.
So,
um,
what's this,
what's that 4th of July?
He's a,
is he,
is he doing sign language?
Big Bird,
all dressed up in American gear?
Horrible.
Richard's obviously,
you know,
he's saying that for the listeners a,
he's a big boy,
you know.
Um,
I don't know exactly the number,
but I would say he's probably in the upper three hundreds.
Okay.
Just for the competitive eater.
I don't,
I'm not familiar with his work,
but I'm excited to look him up.
I like to know is Dietz,
but I'm trying to make it clear and so people listening,
but when he says,
you know,
I'm uh,
I might,
my appearance might not.
It's because he's a real big guy.
Right.
Okay.
I know my,
you know,
my parents buy it for you.
I'm,
I'm on,
been on a giant diet and life changing stuff.
Um,
I've dropped to about a hundred pounds in eight months.
Good man,
that's crazy.
Was even,
he was a hundred pounds heavier than this.
Good job,
Richard.
So we're going to consider this my cheat day for the here,
but you know,
prepping just gallons of water.
But you know,
I have two giant inspirations.
First,
my wife,
second anniversary today.
I want to say hi to her.
And,
um,
there's a comedian I love,
he's a big,
giant fat guy,
just like me,
Bert Chrysler,
and uh,
you know,
and if he can do what I can do it and he's still way bigger than I am.
But you know what,
maybe I can inspire him.
There you go.
It's so good.
What a wonderful thing.
That was amazing.
What a treat that is.
Fat.
Um,
that was so good.
That was so real to,
we didn't,
we didn't ask them to do that or it's not Richard Franco.
Thank you Richard.
I know that you didn't when Nathan's,
but you won our fucking hearts today.
You're the kind of being that is amazing.
I got to tell you.
Um,
you know,
I feel like the way jokes go on the show.
Yeah.
Sometimes you were like,
what happened to this bit?
And it's like,
you know,
it's just like naturally hanging out with your friends.
Things dip away.
Yes.
Am I feeling was this bird thing is going to take the natural dip,
right,
right.
That was just like,
you know,
um,
what's his name,
the boxer crazy.
Lokes or right,
right.
Or,
um,
Shane Lee or any,
you know,
or the,
uh,
Friday,
Thursday layers.
Those are the things where like people come up.
Uh,
there's jokes about it.
There's just a natural way that things come up and about.
But I actually feel like as we're thinking this is going to dip down,
I think it's actually going to rev up.
It's gained momentum.
It's gaining momentum because Burt is also now more invested.
He was like playing the victim card for a while and now he's like,
he sent out a tweet that said basically Tom,
brace yourself for what I'm going to do to you.
And he said,
reverse revenge is a best is it?
Is a dish best served cold?
And then everyone was like,
of course you're referencing food,
you fat shit.
But,
um,
but I really feel like it's about to actually,
I think it's actually gotten bigger than we,
it's because we don't even,
people sometimes will say to us,
Oh,
you know,
you mentioned the Burt jokes again.
And I'm like,
yeah,
dude,
you have no idea how little we're talking about this.
Yeah.
The momentum of it.
It's become its own movement.
It's taken over Wikipedia.
I think they changed birth.
They trade,
they changed to ride day,
produce Wikipedia page,
Gerard dip our dues Wikipedia page,
at least for a few days last week,
said that he bears an uncanny resemblance to big fat Slob,
communion.
Burnt Chrysler,
that is an internationally acclaimed actor.
Burt's Wikipedia page has been,
Jack Burns was completely hijacked.
Um,
things like this.
Like Richard's amazing.
Thank [inaudible] talking about a big fat guy named Bert.
He has,
he's bigger than me,
is way bigger than me,
but if I can inspire the way Richard does it,
it's perfect.
It's perfect.
You really slid it in.
So naturally it's like my,
my wife knows this guy and then he,
he does it and the,
Oh,
so like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Just masterfully.
He really mastered no prepping,
just gallons of water.
I have two giant inspirations.
First,
my wife,
it's our second anniversary today.
I want to say hi to her university.
And um,
there's a comedian I love,
he's a big giant fat guy just like me,
Burke Christ lake.
And uh,
you know,
you can do it.
I can do it.
You still way bigger than I am,
but you know what?
Maybe I can inspire him.
There you go.
He's so sincere,
which really good.
Richard.
So earnest and they're having some pictures floating around on Twitter of Bert,
like on the travel channel show.
And he really is just enormous right now.
Oh my God.
He really is.
He's actually,
it did,
it was a joke.
And then the pictures,
like somebody took a snapshot of him hosting the show and they,
and it was a radio host in Indianapolis and you won't get this,
but sports fans will he go next to birth picture?
He put fat Andrew Luck,
which is the quarterback for the colts.
Burton looks like him,
but like a thousand power.
Yeah.
So people are doing that and then they're doing still shots.
Right.
The screen grabs of him like in that pool where he's like,
he looks like he's 13 months pregnant or like a little kid is just looking
straight at the stomach.
Yeah,
so I'm also,
I'm actually
also really,
I'm really interested at what he's got.
He's got something planned.
He has done some planning.
Yeah.
I don't think it's as big as this is the biggest thing.
We got this victory with Richard here I think,
and we didn't even plan on prompted.
Yeah.
Prompted.
This is just this guy is brilliant work here.
I feel like you can't really top that.
This dude.
I'm,
I'm waiting and I already have a comeback.
You and I have been talking in,
in private behind closed doors.
Possible retaliation.
I don't,
we're not going to disclose,
disclose it,
but it would,
it'd be mass seriously up the game a lot.
It would be insane.
I'm really hoping that we,
well,
let's see.
Let's see what Bert,
he'll throw down the gauntlet and will retaliate if necessary.
I mean I feel like it's an ambush.
That's what I feel like that sweet suggests you're not going to be ready for it
and that's when it's going to get you.
Okay.
Well,
let's see.
It's so funny.
Even my cousin just randomly today was like,
Oh,
I've been looking at Hashtag Burdis fat on Instagram.
Just seeing what there is,
there's tons of shit.
Does that Hashtag Burdis fat?
It's,
it's taken over and people have,
I always say it's great.
Most people that listen to this show,
I'll give you credit
or really,
really funny with it.
Oh yeah.
Some people are mean and I feel like sometimes it's like,
it's too mean.
You know,
like I'll send,
I mean I get the tweets too and then I'm like,
Jesus,
like the,
there'll be really mean.
But some of them are just super well,
like whatever.
Like yeah,
this is really clever that it nailed it.
Really Great.
He's a giant fat guy like me.
Yeah,
that's what he said.
Giant.
Great,
great big giant fat guy like me.
Yeah.
Um,
so anyways,
that's,
that's amazing.
That was the best thing.
So special.
Thank you.
What a,
what a treat.
What a neat,
neat trade.
That was.
Incredible.
So anyway,
I want to see how Richard did.
I didn't,
I only saw the headline that Joey chestnut one.
I don't know.
Was he at the Nathan's or was this a different one?
I don't,
I'm not sure.
I don't know.
I have to look him up.
There's an IOC website and you can see all the competitive eaters there and it
gives their stats and like what they're good at and stuff.
Hmm.
Well we'll see.
We'll see.
Uh,
Nathan's right.
Nathan's.
Yeah,
I tell you anything.
We'll see if,
uh,
Jesus,
he,
he regains a hot dog eating title and sets a record today.
And you already said that he,
he drinks gallons of water to expand the stomach.
That's how they train.
You think they trained by eating?
It's not that it's,
it's they train the stomach muscle because that's what it is.
So they expanded La a few weeks before that.
Kobayashi was really good at it cause he was physically fit and he would train
his stomach too.
He was,
he was really good at it.
So it looks like a,
yeah.
Um,
but then there was some weird thing with the,
the league in him.
Let's ashy man,
what are you looking at?
I was looking to see if there's like a list of the results might be too soon.
Yeah.
All right.
Anyways,
yeah,
go ahead.
No,
I'm just,
uh,
I just thought we'd bring up some topics of what happened in our lives this
week.
We had to take Betsy to the Er.
Oh my God.
Finally
for her eating something toxic.
Uh,
after Saturday,
Saturday night,
we fed her dinner and she was running around the backyard with a fief and she
ran into a Rose Bush and just like kept on Roland.
I was going out to dinner with a sickle cell.
I was going to go to the comedy store to do my spot and Uber on the way it was
actually out front.
By the time,
you know,
this happened and her little legs,
her hind legs kind of collapsed on her,
her,
and she was woozy and she wouldn't respond to us and she just looked like sec.
Like this dog was no good.
So we throw in the car,
we cancel our plans for the night,
we go to the Er,
the doggy Er of course.
And what happens as we park,
what happens?
Bounce right back.
Right back.
Bad.
Nothing.
Like nothing was wrong,
nothing was wrong.
So she ate something Shitty I think.
And then it just kind of flushed out of her system.
I don't know.
She wasn't fine ever since,
but they got,
that saved us about a thousand dollars and you know dog er,
you know,
cause they pulled that bullshit on you like oh we should keep it here overnight
and given an ivy and all this nonsense should continue the same behavior.
You have to do it.
Yeah.
We literally halfway through drought I'm like,
I think she's already a little better.
Yeah.
Cause she was licking my hand and for a second it was really scary.
She like was not responding and she was like,
I thought she had a concussion.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I run into a roadblock but have,
then we got to the place and she was sniffing lick and stuff and she was like,
is this a play place?
She came back to life.
Thank goodness.
That was quite a scare.
It was very scary.
I hate,
I hate that when that whole skiff safe,
man,
I don't want feed was sick though.
When we first got him,
it was horrible and that was fucking worse.
The other thing is that with a,
with fee,
if they were like,
it's $1,000 a day,
a day.
I remember the day,
I know we did a fundraiser show and oh my God,
we saved his life is great.
It's the best thing.
But tonight is his least favorite night of all,
all year.
He hates tonight more than any.
Most doggies.
This is scary night for animals.
Don't say a fucking thing.
Yeah,
it's scary.
It's a fireworks.
They hate it.
Cats and dogs loose.
I'm sure I'll animals.
I don't know what's happening is my dog and hope.
Fuck the Shit Outta you.
Don't pet my dog,
asshole,
asshole.
Linkedin is helpful like Lincoln.
Then I don't fucking like,
hey,
so Lincoln,
did I tell you that I became obsessed with Dan Pena this week?
Well,
yeah.
I mean,
it was kind of a big hit on the show and a big hit in my heart.
I knew you were going to love it.
I love it.
And I did an episode of,
that's deep bro on him this week.
It's already dropped if you want to hear it.
And I get really into him.
So I researched and I read his website.
I read his Ebook,
I watched all the videos I could.
He's basically an old school.
He's my dad's age,
so he's just old school military guy.
Um,
not so much shish wads of eve though.
I'll tell you that.
Like he's,
he's got $50 billion,
but he doesn't have fun with it ever.
Like,
because his whole thing is,
he goes,
I work seven days a week,
20 hours a day.
I slept for four hours a night.
And you're like,
why?
Why,
Why do you have 50 billion?
You're not even enjoying it.
Your wife probably can't stand it.
It's,
um,
it's a little,
it's a little much.
Well,
what's the difference between 50 million and for hanging out with losers?
Like wasting your time with people that meet,
correct.
Correct.
Show me your friends and I'll show you the future.
That's one of your top.
It is three pieces.
Show me your friends and I show you your future.
You want to know why you're all fucked up.
Just look at the fucking bomb to hang around with.
You know,
he said that to his kids.
Fucking love it.
Now my father literally said those words to me.
You a friend is a goddamn loser.
This guy's a fucking losers.
Was real big on lose on a foreign lexicon.
Losers.
Yeah.
My Dad told me my friends will lose a lot and he's right.
He was right,
but he was fucking right that says,
why your fucking whore?
Um,
so yeah,
you had him on mind.
I just,
I discussed it and uh,
his dad was a policeman.
I think his dad was a hard knock sky on him.
Oh.
And I had,
um,
pat McAfee on charge it to the game.
A lot of people were recommending him before he does stand up and he's a punter
in the NFL and it's all,
my God,
it's really hilarious.
In the conversation we had.
So check it out,
charge it to the game.
Pat McAfee,
the kickoff specialist,
punter holder for the Indianapolis Colts.
Really funny.
Um,
so yeah,
so Dan Pena,
there you go.
He's my new hero.
He's crazy.
It's great.
I just,
you know what it is.
I,
I do miss.
I miss these people.
I miss this time of our dads like guys that just say shit,
they're gone.
Everybody's so afraid of hurting people's fucking feelings.
And this is just an old school way of being.
And it's not entirely wrong.
The guys kind of right about a lot of stuff,
hanging out.
Losers.
You're going to be a loser.
His whole thing too.
It's so funny.
On his website,
he's like,
just fucking do it.
Stop being a fucking cunt.
It just fucking do it.
And I think moving to the UK,
really up to his usage of the word cunt.
He says it a
lot.
Yeah.
That is a,
I know.
But when you hear an American say it like as he does,
heck yeah.
It sounds,
you're like she Christ.
Yeah.
He's like,
you fucking cunt.
You're a fucking cunt really tossing around.
It's great.
I love it.
I listened to him.
I know he has a podcast is not very good.
He's not a good pod caster.
Yeah,
but it's ask,
they ask him anything.
He reads like a question and answered it in three seconds,
then moves onto the next one.
He's like,
how do I get this time?
You fucking go do it.
And the next question is like,
yeah,
that's how he does his find guys.
And he's like,
yeah,
Dan,
how do I become successful?
Like okay,
that's all my fucking website.
It's all there.
It's all fucking free wipes.
That's every answer is go to my fucking website.
We're in fucking say,
it's so great.
And 11,
I don't know where he gets the $50 billion man from.
I don't know what happened.
Know what it is,
is that he was catchy.
It's a good marketing,
but he was a CEO of some company and then he got fired,
but he made the company a lot of money and then he became a coach immediately.
Like he's like,
I got fired.
And then the next day I started coaching people and then he started the Scotland
Castle thing.
But you know how he makes his money is he charges you $20,000 a pop to go to his
seminar Scotland.
Right.
And he says to you,
focus on the few,
not the many meaning like you,
you get $20,000 from 10 people versus $1.
We are,
you see the little room he's in,
it's probably 10,
15 people Max,
right?
Yeah.
And suits.
They're all sitting there like it.
Of course.
I'm sure he's like,
don't dress like a fucking shithead in my class.
Yeah.
He works out twice a day.
Dan Pena,
that's part of his 20 hour day and he's 70 years old.
He sleeps four hours.
He is the wife who's also a high achiever.
So she understands the signs to intense.
Yeah,
he's super intense by the way.
Super Fun.
Somebody wrote in right
to us.
Um,
on reddit there's a subreddit for the show.
So a lot of people,
I might not know that,
but a lot of activity and it's a,
it's a,
it's a good place.
A lot of funny things are posted there.
Somebody on reddit asked,
hey,
mommy's sorry for being dense and maybe this whole thing going is going right
over my head,
but I can't figure out if the whole,
Ooh Baby Jesus,
Ooh,
he's having a rough night.
Yeah.
We had to reschedule our recording today,
but people don't know that.
Yeah,
this is,
we usually record her in the day.
Yeah.
This is a night to been orange or sitter for the,
for when we do the show.
Uh,
sick.
I want to stop.
Should we stop,
pause and see how he goes.
Hold on.
Start this over again.
Okay.
We're back.
Uh,
is he,
is he?
Yeah,
he's,
I think he's okay.
You put your dad glasses on and tell your dad powers.
Powers through the walls.
Um,
so I should get back to this email please.
Yeah,
so he says I can't figure it out.
The whole salad.
My thing is real or real or a joke.
Totally real.
If so,
or time on Christina [inaudible] or somebody playing a joke on them.
God.
It seems hard to believe and I feel like an idiot for not being able to tell
what it is.
Thanks.
High and tight.
Dude.
I appreciate you posting this,
but this is,
here's what,
it's all real.
You joined the show later,
but here's what happened.
Christina got a new phone number,
months and months,
I don't know how long ago,
a year ago now.
And there was a series of text messages and phone calls from different for
different people.
Yeah.
One was for a dude,
eight is who
we should tell you what.
Shenaz is a nurse and she's allowed nursing opportunities.
She's not hearing about Aiden gets calls every other week.
Hey,
this has a serious substance abuse problems and a mental illness.
Yeah.
And people are always trying to help them and be like,
are you okay?
Are you got to Rehab?
And then like,
Hey,
I got pills,
I got sticks on deck and all that.
Yes.
And then Salamay is Persian lady and has a friend who never sees her in real
life but leaves her relentless voice mails.
And it's definitely not,
I mean that would cause it to elaborate on the journey.
Even show you and I will just,
I've saved the voicemails.
Hold on.
I saved the Persian lady.
These are,
this is my real phone.
This is not a joke.
Um,
well why don't I,
here,
I'll show you
guys this.
This is not a joke.
Oh,
should I need that one?
Yeah,
you might want to,
uh,
here I keep them for the show blue band.
If you want to.
This says Persian lady.
This is,
this is just hide the top number.
That eight one eight number.
If you could discreetly kind of push it up.
Camera.
These I,
I've actually had to create an ad,
like a contact number for Persian lady because I get these calls so frequently.
So we're also so that we never answer,
right.
Accident the accident.
Yeah.
So this,
I guess this number like three people have had and they don't let other people
know that they've changed number and then this is 100% real.
I mean you can tell by the translations that we get to that this is like,
this is an old lady calling another old lady about some nonsense,
but she never stopped.
She never gets,
I mean the weird thing is maybe she does see this lady regularly,
never goes like,
hey,
did you get my phone?
I think so.
Or The lady goes,
yeah,
I got your message and is just,
you know,
when old people just go like,
like I told you,
I saw that guy at the place the week after I,
you know,
I saw a guy had uh,
getting my haircut,
old guy and I go outside your last time.
And he goes,
yeah,
we had a nice talk.
And I know we didn't.
Oh right.
But he just said that and I didn't correct him.
Yeah.
Maybe it's that where she,
you know,
oh,
it's this,
it's this.
That's fine.
I think what it is with Salamay is that she has this person's the,
she has salamis old number,
which is my number one,
and maybe it's a long ways,
new number.
So she,
I think she goes back and forth.
You now I contact save and you don't necessarily see a number.
So I think she,
she had sell them.
They are talking right.
Obviously cause the update about the squirrel and the bags and the law firm and
the thing.
But she's messages at the old number and she's not aware that she's doing that.
Yeah.
Cause I've done that.
Haven't,
you know like we were like your dad's old number and then you don't even look at
it.
Yeah.
It's just the content.
Sometimes I have friends who
have changed number so many times and at 1.01 of my friends contacts and add
four numbers and I had to finally at like,
which of these should I delete?
Right,
right.
I've had them for too,
too long.
Hello?
Hello mate.
Thanks a lot.
She goes [inaudible] time.
Would you find in the grocery man bought it immediately or not?
You know?
Oh my God.
Oh mighty God.
[inaudible] they're up there.
I hadn't dealt with.
It's just,
it's crazy man.
It's outrageous.
It's all real.
Yeah.
Hello?
[inaudible] bag on my [inaudible] Saturday misery or not right?
No Salamander.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
I'm at this one.
Oh my goodness.
[inaudible] recording.
I'm not home depot.
All right.
Right here
I is total main blog and Danny's mother fuckers.
Big Sketch.
Hope the boss or my God.
Oh my God.
For one month.
I mean,
no,
from Sherry.
Very up to now in the ball.
[inaudible] mother,
father [inaudible] she was,
she was saying,
Huh?
Somebody wrote in that this was,
it's super crass.
The way she's speaking in Farsi too.
Yeah.
Then she's saying like Condon a whore.
She's an old lady.
You can tell.
Yeah.
All school lady.
Wow.
Mary,
you go.
Solomon is a,
it's very real,
my man.
It's not,
it's not a prank.
We want the calls to stop.
Seriously.
Just don't,
it's a good,
I would say that everything on your mom's house is,
our lives are,
we don't make up stuff on the show now.
We even,
some of you share too much.
I'd made it.
Yeah.
A thing that,
um,
we don't want fake,
you know,
we always go like,
oh,
is it fake?
And we get bumped up.
And you don't like the,
you know,
we like to play jokes but we don't like to play like,
like fake video.
Yes.
Sometimes they're not real.
Like this guy's reacting to his sister.
Farty and it's not a real,
we don't play it.
Sounds good.
Yeah,
it's definitely not as good.
Anyways.
Um,
also update.
There is a cookie thief in the house.
Do you know anything about this?
I don't.
You want to,
it's so weird because I had burnt so fat.
Yeah.
Well your,
your uncle Dave,
we saw your family yesterday and he handed two special cookies that he brought
from Ohio and they were wrapped special wedding cookies,
right?
Yeah.
And I had them in my purse and I remember thinking,
I can't wait to eat these cookies tomorrow.
And then this morning I looked and there was a,
just a rapper with no cookie inside just sitting on the credenza and the living
room.
Do you know what happened?
And there's only one cookie left in my purse.
I might have done it.
You think he snuck in last night?
Also our,
you know,
or babysitter or nanny help.
They have a key.
She has a key.
So you think the nanny snuck in last night around 9:00 PM ate that cookie and
wrapper on the credential.
But anytime overnight.
Cause when we were,
while we were,
should we add this?
You didn't show up today.
Right.
That sounds like a real guilty thing to do.
I just can't believe that somebody had the audacity to rummage through my purse
because we never,
I never discussed the cookies that anybody y'all go,
Dave gave them to me and the audacity of somebody in this house to image through
my belongings,
eat the cookie and then not even bother to hide the evidence.
Wow.
And you fire her.
I'll support you.
I'll stand there and I will definitely have your back
and be like,
you're fucking fired.
I just,
I can't,
I saw,
I'm sorry I can't get over the fact that somebody just left the rat.
I'm disappointed too.
I'm really disappointed.
Yeah.
Well I'm glad we got that out of the way and uh Huh.
Yeah,
it's weird that she could be my mom.
Wait,
that's not it.
It's weird that you would,
uh,
she would,
she would
just leave the wrapper.
Oh,
there's going to be a interesting frame jump.
We'll jump cut.
Interesting.
Blue Angels had a very groundbreaking,
why don't you,
why don't you tell everybody we spoke over the phone a couple of days ago and
while we were talking,
all of a sudden I just heard the touch tone sound.
Thank you.
Smash the phone with your face that I have to say this.
I don't fucking think so.
You're becoming top dog.
I hate to tell you this,
but you are,
and you becoming him so much that the other day you walked in the room and you
didn't do this.
Like ironically you,
you meant that you were like,
you go,
I had a couple,
a really good farts today and you did not do it as a joke.
You were earnest.
No Bull Shit.
I had a couple of good farts today.
I said that and then,
um,
yeah,
no,
but the joke that I did to you earlier today,
I said you want to hear a cool fart?
That's such a good one.
Stick.
This soldier was.
Yes.
People that like live
have fun and if you're a listener,
I think that'd be a really fun thing to try to incorporate into your life.
Marriage and your marriage would also like to your parents,
to your friends,
to your siblings.
Say you want to hear a cool fart right before you have to want to hear a cool
fart and then probably be like,
yeah,
then you do it.
Nobody says yes,
but you didn't say yes,
of course not.
Why don't you want to hear a cool fart?
I hear them all the time with you.
I spent,
this one was really cool and I was holding it on to,
you know what's so crazy?
If you guys are listening and you have a spouse,
have you ever had a fart that smells like your spouses?
Like I farted in bed and it smelled like one of your farts.
Isn't that special?
That's pretty neat.
I didn't think that that was the case.
I thought it smelled just like your stinky ass hole,
but
energy is now.
You call it synergy.
I should have.
Yeah,
that is synergy.
But I tried to put a posted on monster Graham last week that I was at the
butthole doctor checking fries.
People that listeners,
yeah,
update.
And so everybody was asking me like,
what happened?
What happened?
What happened was nothing.
We just did a,
it was just like a get to know your butthole.
He,
uh,
he just wants to run tests.
Did he check your oil?
No,
but it's going to come up.
He said he's going to check your oil now for a while though.
He's busy.
Buy Holes are busy,
but we're going to wait for you to suffer the way I have the last year and a
half.
He now that,
you know,
narrow sense.
It's funny.
It's just how it always is.
You know,
if you're,
will you fucking stop.
He's like,
you know,
if you're like my shoulder hurts and then you go to the doctor,
you're shore.
It doesn't hurt.
Ever since I've gone to him,
I feel much healthier in the Gi track.
Yeah,
seriously.
You know what it may have been.
What?
I've cut out those heavy breakfasts we were having,
we've been having like smoothies.
I did.
I also called a food allergist,
so I'm finally going to get tested for food allergies.
I bet there's some stuff going on.
Yeah,
I think there's some stuff closely.
I'm not going to end up all Bert.
I'm going to check it out.
No.
Oh Bert,
I like that.
Also want to tell people that a new Patriot episode went up episode three on
Patrion and there's all kinds of goodies in there.
Somebody mentioned even in an email like what's up with FIFA Nader,
we haven't heard him speak in a while.
The Fif is on the latest Oh,
episode two has fif and he's going to be back on your mom's house.
We talked to him.
He said he wants to come on and next week,
so you can definitely get to know fif again next week because it has been
awhile.
But he did make an appearance on,
on Patrion episode too.
So did Betsy.
Betsy talked in episode two.
They'll both come on the show.
Don't worry.
It's not that we're keeping them over there.
They just happened to come on when we were doing the Patriot were also
negotiating rates with fif on the double pipe.
Classic shirts.
We're in negotiations with him now,
which is why he's not on today's episode.
And,
and many thanks to everybody that ordered a double pipe classic.
They're very rare.
Double Pipe classic shirts.
We actually had to reorder because so many of you already.
Yeah,
it's a good shirt.
It's really a nice shirt.
I wear mine in Pve,
like water based ink,
I think they call it.
It's soft.
It's a good looking shirt and a,
it's a good way to celebrate.
Um,
having a double pipe or even yearning to have one.
People have told me,
can I wear one if I've,
I feel like a fraud.
And it's like,
well,
can you dream?
Of course you can.
That's the first time I've seen you drink water this week.
How Fun.
I haven't been paying attention cause I probably had like 70 gallons this week.
Oh,
please.
You know,
I've been getting a lot of Twitter support from my end in this.
People realizing you're showboating and you're bullshitting.
And the truth is I hydrate constantly.
You just hydrate for the cameras and people are catching on.
People are catching on
amazed to flow and your age to know when I have an age to showboating because
I'm the one who actually drink the coffee.
My Dad came over,
uh,
yesterday.
Was that fun.
Yeah.
And brought a friend,
Jeff,
all of them.
So some an interesting things.
Shared some knowledge.
This time was neat.
We talked about talking about parenting.
He's very bothered by it.
He said it was,
I think at the pool somewhere to pull in.
He goes,
uh,
you know,
these kids were in the pool every two seconds.
People were like,
good job.
Good job.
Yeah,
for the fucking swimming.
Good job.
You say it too much.
You know,
they should wait til the end of the day and then one time you go,
you did a good job today,
right?
I was like,
Dad,
so you don't,
you don't want to build up a kid's confidence too much.
Right?
And he's like,
no,
of course not.
How'd they got to know?
They do a good job.
I'm like,
that's good.
Thank you.
Do you think we're overdoing it?
He thinks rob,
we're doing it.
Not Us.
Just society.
Society with making kids feel good about themselves.
He might have a point about how some,
some occasions that can be overdone.
I think saying good job to a kid,
learning how to swim.
I think that's okay.
I think you probably do that.
You should.
Yeah.
Good job.
I agree.
Especially if they're really young.
So that was nice.
Two,
three years old.
No,
just once.
Once a day to day.
Yeah.
I don't think my dad really,
uh,
gave me a lot of praise.
Clearly somebody pointed out.
Speaking of water,
the,
I wrote an email to your water champ and other mommy.
Christina.
Okay.
I think I figured out why Tina thinks she's the water champ.
Really as you can here.
At what hour?
Eight minutes.
10 seconds of episode three 42 we're in.
Tina thinks Tom's dental story is her own.
Obviously this means never.
Tom Takes a drink of hydrating and refreshing.
Hto a Chabot.
Tina believes she took a drink of water as well.
I think this is where the confusion comes from.
And I think you're correct,
sir.
Thank you for writing into us.
Are you choosing the emails that are being read this week?
These are,
uh,
on the cheese thing.
Yeah.
That's a good theory that came in.
Interesting.
Thanks.
Blue Band.
Good job.
Got Someone got a raise.
Yup.
Interesting is correct.
That's interesting point.
Very,
very interesting.
I'm here,
I'm going to show you this.
Okay.
Uh,
this is Mr Hydrea put that down.
Sean Lynch.
I've heard his name before.
You've talked about him.
Yes.
This is a great clip.
Uh,
he's talking about,
you know,
playing foosball.
Do you call it?
Yeah.
And I'll just let him be load.
Yeah,
that's his nickname.
His bottom teeth.
A scissor weird.
What's going on there?
There's some gold.
I like baby teeth,
but then there's two naturals in the front.
Those are all right.
If you just run through somebody's face,
a lot of people ain't gonna be able to take that over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and over and over and over and over and over
and over and over again.
They just knocked on mount that because the deeper metaphor there running
through a motherfucker face.
Yeah.
Love it up.
I love it.
Yeah.
Over,
over,
over it.
He's right now shine or play around.
Oh,
I like it.
What does he play again?
What team?
Well,
he just retired.
He played for Seattle.
Nice.
I like him.
Yeah.
What,
how else,
what else do we know him?
Why do I know his name?
Why do you know Marshawn lynch?
What else did we played of his,
that he's,
is he funny?
Yeah,
I mean he's,
he's uh,
he's definitely one of the bigger personalities of the last decade in the NFL.
He did this thing for,
um,
he hated the media,
basically hated being ordered to speak to them.
It's in your contract.
I agree with him.
He did this press conference where you have,
you're obligated to spend,
let's say in the super bowl,
the press conferences leading up to it 15 minutes so you can to the media.
It's just a contractually,
right.
So whatever he was asked,
he would go,
I'm here.
So they don't find me.
And then they really,
what are you worried at all about what?
Denver.
My,
I'm here so they don't find me.
That's what's up.
And then there's a good,
how are you feeling since getting here?
He's like,
I'm here to stay.
They don't find me.
Yup.
And it's all he said.
Good for him.
Yeah.
I think it's horrible that they ask you how you feel after you've lost a game.
Was this before the game or even before?
He doesn't want to talk to the media.
He wants to get in his own head.
Get into zone.
Yeah,
I'll him,
they find him for that.
I don't know if they find him for that Saturday,
I think I remember doing,
I remember it well.
He did this thing during the,
before that where he was getting fined for.
Never speaking.
Like,
at first it was like,
I'm not,
so they were just asking him,
he wouldn't respond and then he came up with some,
some answer.
There was also like a really dismissive answer.
I like him all.
I forget what it was,
and then it became,
I'm here so they don't find me.
So it was like,
it was a progression to that.
Good for him.
Yeah.
He's my new favorite hymn and Allen Iverson timeout practice over over again.
They're just not all along with that.
I think there's a deeper metaphor there were onto a Ma Fucka face.
Yup.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's true.
I like him.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a really good way of looking at things actually.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could,
I think Dan Pena would like that,
but you think I,
yeah,
of course.
Yeah,
Of course.
Then you would be like,
you should run through a motherfucker face.
Get that cotton.
Fucking fuck him in the face.
They can bugger off fucker.
Yeah.
Um,
he swabbed his 60 minute break,
one dinner right at Taco Bell.
And I couldn't even get no mother case.
A dealer
case dealer.
Marshawn's got personality.
Yeah,
I liked that guy.
Yeah.
You know,
if he's not really feeling it,
he just can't do it.
Why can't I walk with my phone?
We had never done a walking shot like this before.
Um,
you know,
he agreed to do it,
but he was kind of on his phone.
I don't even think he was,
he was facetiming somebody.
I asked him,
can we just,
can we take that again?
But maybe you're not talking on the phone this time,
but he,
he,
he wasn't
all know you as the worst.
The worst in my Damn Mama.
Huh?
That's great.
I love,
love that guy.
Might see some needles on the ground term.
I see some Thai rigs,
you know what I'm saying though?
The sharp had to stay on your toes.
How's that impact?
You've seen that as a kid?
I think it impact me to be prepared to deal with y'all.
If you come to me with something,
I'm probably going to see that a mile away.
Love it.
My new favorite,
but see,
it seems like you like what a lot of people like,
which is authentic people.
He's,
he keeps it 104,
like four.
I like it too.
All Shit.
That's why I was drawn to Dan Pena to
live your life that way.
Well,
I was just 20 years and years Miley.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
No,
I spent all week with Dan Pena when I've met people like that.
I'm the same way.
Yeah,
it's not,
I mean,
the cursing I do like,
I'd like people to love it,
but it's just,
it's the,
um,
it's people that aren't trying to make you,
trying to please you.
They genuinely being this.
That's why people tell you to be yourself when you really are these guys like
Marshawn and Pena.
Actually,
what they have in similarity with each other is that they are both authentic.
Zero fucks given oh zero fucks given,
but they're being true to themselves.
You know who's like that is top dog too.
I'm not exactly,
top dog doesn't get it.
Doesn't care.
No.
My favorite about top dog and so when a force today buddy,
that stuff,
but then it's like top dog.
Do you want to go to Italy?
Asked,
I've dog if he wants to go to France or Italy.
Yeah.
Why not top dog for what made you go,
wow,
I'm pretty amazing artifacts.
Museums there.
He's like,
yeah,
I think about a museum art museum.
You walk in,
you see it,
and then you saw it.
It was like,
I don't need to see it.
Thank you.
Saw It,
you know.
But that's why I love that same picture on online.
I can look it online.
Yeah.
And also what I love is that your dad has zero tolerance for small talk or
socializing too,
for maybe not even to a fault.
He talked to me,
he and I jam out.
Yeah.
Cause I'll talk about war with him all day.
I want to talk about Alan's people making conversation best a little much.
Yeah.
Walks away from people as they're talking to him.
I know happened at a wedding.
Somebody goes,
don't think you're old man like me that much.
And I go,
why is that?
And he goes,
well you know,
he said something and I asked,
then he asked me something and I was answering.
He walked away.
No.
Yeah.
It's just,
that's,
that's because that person was boring topic.
He was born and he talk about the stuff talking and telling me.
Well the thing is that you're boring.
You're fucking boring him.
Top Dog and I,
we took that cruise in Cincinnati on the river that day.
Yeah.
Your Dad and I sat on the top deck and we wrapped for like 30 kids.
30 minutes to do though.
I love your dad cause he didn't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck and we don't give a fuck together.
Right.
And it's really fun.
Yeah.
I tried not giving a fuck with your family yesterday and I was penalized and
peer pressured.
Yeah.
And to going on a fucking walk that I didn't want to go on.
It's so funny that you said so.
This is the best.
We're at my cousin units house and her parents are in town.
My uncle Dave and Blanca,
they've been,
they've been here before.
They've been on the show before.
Um,
I think it was actually a,
uh,
a phone call that they did on,
maybe it was on a,
on a bonus episode.
If you go back to like the,
um,
the,
what's it called?
Itunes bonus episodes.
So why don't you can buy on Amazon.
And once I called,
yeah,
all right.
Told me that last time.
And your mom and she said,
Oh,
me,
she told me is making that up.
I have,
I have a recording of her saying it
did.
You had a kid in no way told me,
I hate to tell you what's happening now.
I ain't going to tell you the truth.
I don't even feel them when they coming out and they said she was just loud.
They said,
teach you just fun the ice if I might,
because I smelled it.
I don't know because I just don't,
they just escape.
That's Blanca.
She's adorable.
She's really adorable.
Um,
Bonnie,
tell exactly what causes that counterpart.
So we were at,
yeah,
Ned's house bribe rise there.
His wife and their daughter.
Yeah.
It's a lot of people.
It was probably,
what,
10,
12,
I don't know.
Anyways,
about our,
no,
10 minutes into it,
they go,
hey,
we're going to go on a walk in a little bit to this beautiful like a point on
the beach.
We were down in Orange County and we go,
okay,
um,
do you want to come?
And I go,
sure.
And I go big.
You want to,
you want to come and you go,
what?
You want to come on this walk?
Can,
you know,
I don't want to go on a walk at all.
And then it sounds horrible.
Everybody else is like,
hey,
we're getting ready for this walk.
And then I heard one of them go,
Hey,
are you coming Christina?
And you go,
no.
And then they go,
are you okay?
And then you go,
yeah.
And then I'm like,
but the thing is I couldn't tell either.
I go,
are you all right?
And you go,
why is there where it has to be filed?
Okay.
That was great.
I was having fun with the kid.
I was playing with Ellis on the floor.
I was like,
why do I want to pick?
This is the fucking walk.
We all leave the place.
And Christy,
I'm going,
so you're staying behind you.
Yeah.
And then as we walked down the hill,
the first,
you know,
a hundred yards a,
I hear Janeka,
Oh hey wait,
wait,
wait.
Christina is coming.
And I go,
okay.
And then you go,
I didn't know I was going to be the only the one that stayed behind.
So you're the only one that was saying,
well because your uncle Dave is antisocial like me too.
And I saw him sitting on the couch and I thought,
oh well he's going to stay behind and we can,
yeah.
Bullshit a little bit.
I didn't want to go on a walk because the problem is one man's idea of what a
wok is is wholly agree.
Totally agree.
Totally.
So how do I know what I'm getting into?
Yeah,
that was all comfortable.
I'm wearing,
you know,
not the right shoes and who goes on a fucking family walk fairly walks or what
Americans do.
What are you talking about?
A lot of Americans do that.
I'm an American.
I never walked.
There was never a walk in my life with the family.
Well,
you weren't raised in,
in American households,
but it is not that uncommon.
I was able to go on,
why do I have to go on a fucking Laura do it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's not even fucking one of us know family walk.
Yeah.
Where would they walk?
Just to go around the block together?
Yeah.
Let me grand.
We only kind of did it like after someone had surgery or something.
You should go walk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just thought like,
why do I have to do everything everyone else is doing?
And then I felt pressured because then your other cousin was like,
are you okay?
I'm like,
I'm fine.
I'm great.
And then you end up ruining my time right now.
More to your point,
there are parts of this walk that were like,
they were not appropriate for a stroller,
Hor horrible store.
I'm like,
dude,
why don't you just say that there's a stairs,
two flights of stairs with this fucking stroller?
And he was like,
oh,
I'll carry the front.
I'm like,
so yeah,
it does.
And then up hill and then at blazing in the,
in the sun.
And the beach and I got an a six month old baby was on the sunscreen on fuel and
you're like,
yeah it is.
But anyways,
it wasn't a stroller walk.
No.
I know the six month and he's getting burned and everything.
I'm like,
come on,
get your life.
So then I took the car ride back with your uncle Dave.
He wants the car.
I'm like me guy got in my car as fast as I could.
Yeah,
I know.
Go on a fucking walk.
Horrible.
I don't want to do anything.
Yeah,
that's the worst.
Check this out.
You'll like this.
Oh Jesus.
That's a shit.
If that shit bro
Tweak or to go back to my teen books,
believe what happened.
So for our listeners,
oh dude is inside his home on the second floor.
Boy was camera running and a guy on the outside just crawled up the side of the
wall and is latched onto the outside of the wall,
cigarette and valleys that you got that shit.
I need my three,
but I got my,
Oh shit.
I forgot my three bucks.
Sheriff Rogers there.
This dude,
you'll never see chick and nurse pipe broken and we ran and then went to cvs.
There was security everywhere.
When I hit this guy and he hit me,
I hit him.
Then he called the cops and they came.
They let me go.
You got to ship.
Oh Wow.
Well there's certainly a purely dollars.
He's setting me up here.
Three hours.
It's wrong house,
Huh?
Oh,
he's,
he's really fucked up looking.
Catch him last year he's got ketchup,
mustard and he's got like 11 d teas,
but their space weird and weird colors.
I know
Jesus Christ as the crack here,
right?
Oh boy.
Oh no crack.
Oh fuck.
You guys don't have crack.
Oh fuck you guys.
Fuck you fucking why people have come back to track.
Okay.
That's a good point.
Next time it's always best to have cracked for people that want crack.
I didn't know you could score crack for three bucks.
I didn't know it was that cheap either.
I thought at least five per rock.
Jesus,
three bucks.
You got to move a lot of rocks to make some profit.
Money.
Yeah.
Be Good on that.
You've got those three bucks.
Yeah.
Jesus.
That's like that wonderful whites.
Yeah.
Like tells like going about these six,
going to sell for nine.
Look,
boot,
scoot and buggy.
Okay.
Hi.
Moneybags.
Three bucks a pill.
Wow.
But I guess all things considered,
it's a pretty cheap habit to have crack.
Yeah.
That's why people would want,
yeah.
In score.
You know
how much is cook?
I've never bought.
No,
don't know.
I wonder,
do you know who is?
Definitely.
It's the,
you know,
it's a higher class.
Yeah.
Raga.
Literally you don't score it for three bucks,
man.
How much coke can I get for three?
They might take one little grain and go like,
there you go.
Yeah.
If you can find that gap closes the smoking crack,
trying to smoke that shit stuff.
You ain't kidding.
How do you have out here smoking that crept into that?
Like you know that it's bad for you.
Everybody knows not to smoke crack at this point.
Right?
Yeah.
Starting it as a really bad thing.
That and heroin when you try heroin,
going to give it a shot.
I think everybody,
it's universally accepted that it's a bad idea.
Oh yeah.
It's real bad.
Oh,
bless
them.
Shits
them shits.
Did you brush today?
Yeah,
your teeth are really dirty.
Thanks.
It looked like thieves teeth.
All right.
I'm Brown and parts,
uh,
do your mommies cow.
That was really gross.
I have a couple of things to tell you.
I've been listening every week for just over a year now.
And because of you,
I went to the dentist for the first time in five years.
The reason I dropped my last dentist was a dick doing things like refusing to
use novacane.
Luckily it wasn't too bad.
Just two cavities.
I feel now that I will be at dentist regular.
Well that's great.
Good for you.
But you don't know who that is.
Friday.
No,
sorry.
Um,
well this next one has the name in it,
but yeah.
Congratulations.
And um,
we definitely encourage you to,
to definitely go to the dentist as often.
I found a guy,
by the way,
when I was at the doctor,
he works in the dentist's office selling a whitening trays for discounts.
The A,
the Gel.
Yeah.
You found a guy?
What?
Here's what happened.
I'm waiting to get my butthole chat.
This is the truth.
Where do you get my butthole check?
The guy in scrubs walks in,
goes to the counter,
and he goes,
Hey,
I work at whatever doctor,
three doors down.
Okay.
Um,
the dentist that's for crack.
Go ahead.
And he goes,
we are moving to whatever,
a new office.
But we wanted to tell people in the building that if you want to get your teeth
whitened,
we're giving it for free to other,
you got to go.
No,
no,
no.
He Goes,
God,
you're the worst God.
You have big teeth and might either.
Perfect.
They're so good.
Then he goes,
I said,
hey,
what did you just say?
I called him out and he goes,
oh,
I'm just doing this.
He goes,
oh,
I liked that you asked.
Well,
we sell the Gel as well.
He goes,
do you have the molds?
I go,
I do.
I have the trades.
He goes,
if you go to this site,
and he gave me like a pass code.
He said,
you can order the gels.
Uh,
the,
the refills stuff for just like wholesale cost.
We have a whole kit,
a fridge full of 90 million we don't take again,
it's on the bottom.
Goddammit.
It's,
I know,
I just fucking saw it yesterday.
You didn't,
I'm telling you it's on the bottom shelf behind the soy milk.
Show me in a fucking blog.
Do show me.
Cause by the way,
no good anymore.
Of course it's good.
No it's not.
We moved with it.
It was out in the fucking,
the gels not going to go bad.
He told me it does go back to bull shit.
Okay,
well anyways,
go buy some more shit.
You're not going to use on your teeth
by the way.
I'm really terrified that I don't have a dentist up here yet.
Calling Gillies pop off.
I am fucked.
How long ago?
And I think about it every day.
Why can't you call and give them?
What do I do?
Do I call and go,
hey,
I'd like to become a patient.
You can I buy that I use for my teeth.
The Jelly,
the Gel already you bought the trays,
you bought the Gel.
You never bothered committing to whitening them.
Have white in them before.
You've done it like three times in the last two years.
Hey,
Mommy's waiting to listen to me ma'am.
Nothing serious.
Central appointment and close to 20 years.
I am 28 years old and I've been too nervous even looking to going for fear of
getting judged.
After listening to you talk about the importance of keeping TVs high and tight
like my jeans,
I bit the bullet.
I am happy to report that I came out of my appointment with only three minor
cavities.
I did find out,
I did find out that I'm going to need my wisdom teeth removed.
That's the worst because my bottom ones grew at a 90 degree angle.
Will cause future issues.
I brush my teeth at least once a day.
Should go for it.
Let's try for twice guys laws,
minimum,
barely regularly.
Every day.
Always use mouthwash.
Thank you for giving me the courage to go to the dentist and step up my teeth
game.
I do have one tough question though.
Wiseberg Chrysler.
So fat.
Excellent question.
We don't know.
Nobody knows.
Um,
but I'm very proud of you for going to the dentist and you should continue to go
and try to up those.
Uh,
can I finish asking my question?
What?
So what do I do?
Do I call it some dentist and I go,
I'm a new patient.
I just want to enroll or something.
Here's what I would do.
Okay.
I would call her,
I would call her old dentist again and I would say,
Hey,
I moved up here.
Yeah.
Do you recommend anybody in this?
He didn't know shit.
Okay.
So that was the first one.
The second one would be call our physician.
Yeah.
Works in that area and say we moved up here.
I used to have a guy down there.
We're up here now.
Can you recommend a dentist?
And he's gonna say yes,
Doctor Dick de dup.
Cool.
But do I call the dentist before my veneers pop off accidentally?
Yes.
Get,
get,
get a yes.
Like get a record already established her.
Do it tomorrow.
Do it.
Look,
I'm writing it on my fucking hand.
Okay.
Ah,
Shit.
I gotta get going.
Oh,
you gotta go?
I gotta go.
What do you got?
You got some shit to do.
Yes.
The way if somebody,
you know,
we played,
I think of soccer guy and I said something like,
Oh,
does no other sports announcers are as passionate as soccer and announcer,
here's a hockey.
Yeah.
That was not as crazy as,
I'm sorry.
Not even close.
It's good for America.
Yes.
America.
American.
They're not Canadian.
Yeah.
No,
that's buffalo.
I mean it was passionate,
but come on.
It's not like the soccer guys were football.
Um,
all right.
Anything else?
Jeans?
You got?
You want to say anything or I Doug's head off
right now.
Um,
no,
I love you guys.
Thanks for listening.
Thank you for listening.
Don't hang out with losers.
Fucking losers.
You wanna know your fucking loser.
Okay.
All right.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Thank you for getting the double pipe classic shirts.
Please sign up for Patrion pay.
Put that down.
And I'm Tom square.com.
Tickets for shows thousand ranch.com for Chris Jeans.
Uh,
anything else?
Anything else?
We're all good.
Right here is a song by,
is it son of nothing?
Yeah.
Son of nothing with the double five classic song.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's all my money.
3:17 PM June 20th,
2016 I witness Tom having a double time classic.
They're extremely rare and you can't force them
applied classes.
It's a surprise.
Just going burp.
Just going to farm.
It happened.
Level five class.
I've classic,
classic,
classic Birch Bark,
Bark,
plastics,
plastics.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't say
you have a mother fucking script.
Fucking monkey.
My pictures are small or you're touching just right though.
Like there's my picture
and we used to drink at lunch.
It was ragged.
Nobody in this fucking room or gone through any kind of pain like especially you
before.
She's worked in.
Everybody understands what he smirked.
Well,
we'll look it up.
Go,
go fucking Facebook,
linkedin,
Twitter,
Google pocket.
And this is you.
You tubers.
Pay attention to what you're fucking con.
Kube,
laughing.
FARC bags,
bags,
because you're off
everybody.
I don't discriminate.
My daughter would say my dad,
he treats everybody the same.
Fixing my shit.
You're a con,
but you're so fucking skill
because you're off.
Merry Christmas to go fuck yourself on that.
Happy note.